Schönen guten Abend Bergs mein Name ich bin zuständig für Sie
bevor wir das hier nach Berlin beschwerden kommen benötige ich einige persönliche Daten
wie heißen Sie denn?
Ja ich heiß Claudia Thomas
Claudia Thomas
Frau Thomas
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen buchstabieren?
Claudia mit C, L, A, U
D, I, A
Danke, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 28 Jahre
Wie waren Sie zu jener Geboren?
Am 7. Februar 1996
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegt sie zur Zeit?
Ich bin 74 und wiegt zur Zeit so 79 kg
Ich habe richtig verstanden 1 Meter 74
1 Meter 74
Danke für die Informationen Frau Thomas
Was haben Sie heute beschwerden?
Ich bin vorhin mit dem Fahrrad hingefallen und zwar bin ich im Dunkel nach Hause gefahren
und da war da so ein Baustellenchild und da habe ich die Baustelle zu spät gesehen
habe stark gebremst und bin dann halt umgekippt
und mein Freund war bei mir
der ist hinter mir hergefahren, der konnte ihn ausweichen
und der hat gesagt ich wäre einen kurzen Augenblick bewusst losgewiesen
und jetzt habe ich halt einmal, musste ich mich übergeben
und ich habe mir hier irgendwie am linken Abend das so sehr weh
und der Bauch tut mir leh und der Kopf
und es hat er schnell das Auto geholt und hat mich hierher gebracht
und mir ist total schlecht
und ich habe das gezogen, das ist alles schmerzhaft und blau hier auf der linken Seite
Okay, ich kann es verstehen
Frau Thomas, wann war dieser Unfall?
Wann bin ich denn nach Hause gefahren?
Das war so viertel nach sechs, dass ich losgefahren bin
das war vielleicht so um kurz nach halb sieben
Okay
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auf Ihrer linken Seite hingefallen sind
und Sie haben kurz Baustellen verloren
Obwohl ich ein Helm auf hatte, ja?
Sie haben Helm getragen
Können Sie Ihren Arm heben?
Ja, nicht wirklich, das tut schon sehr weh
Ich halte den ein, ich halte den immer mit dem anderen Arm fest
damit ist es erträglich, aber es tut sehr weh
Schmerzhaft
Ja, sehr schmerzhaft
Könnten Sie Ihren linken Enden bohren und linken Handgelenk bewegen?
Die Hand kann ich bewegen, ja
Elbogen, das tut weh, aber die Hand kann ich ein bisschen bewegen, ja
Okay
In Ihrem linken Schulter haben Sie eine Schwellung, oder Verstellung?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das die Schulter, aber hier oben fängt sich das alles dick und schmerzhaft an, ja
Okay
Aber ich glaube auch, an der Hüfte und so, da habe ich wahrscheinlich auch etwas abgegreht
Also die ganze Seite tut mir weh, ne?
Haben Sie auch linker Hüfte schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich überall so ein bisschen mich gestoßen habe, ne?
Haben Sie jetzt ein Luftnot, oder ein Brustschmerz?
Brustschmerz, nein, nein, das habe ich nicht
Brustschmerzen haben Sie keine
Man bohren kann es ein bisschen weh, ja
Wow
In Ihrem linken Schulter, linken Arm, haben Sie auch Krippen oder Tauffaustgefühle?
Ne, das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, ne, ne, das tut nur alles weh
Nur Schmerzen
Das reicht aber auch
Haben Sie das Gefühl, dass die Temperatur unterschiedlich zwischen beiden Händen oder beiden Armen bemerkt?
Ich glaube nicht, nein
Okay
Okay, Frau Thomas
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie einmal erbrochen haben
Ja
Können Sie das erinnern, wie das Erbrochen aussah?
Ne, das war ja da ein Dunkeln auf der Straße, wo der Unfall passiert ist, ja?
Das war direkt nach dem Unfall, als ich da wieder aufgewacht bin
Ich war ja ganz kurz weg, also das kann nur eine Minute oder so gewesen sein
Aber wie gesagt, mein Freund sagte, ich wäre kurz nicht ansprechbar gewesen
Und als ich dann wieder zu mir gekommen bin, dann habe ich mich halt aufgerappelt
Und dann musste ich mich da gleich, da an der Unfallstelle, habe ich mich übergeben
Mhm
Bitte wissen, wie wurden Sie bei uns gekommen?
Ja, mein Freund hat das Auto schnell geholt und hat mich hierher gebracht
Mhm
Okay
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auch Bauchschmerzen haben
Ja
Wo genau haben Sie diese Bauchschmerzen spüren, verspüren?
Ja, eigentlich so, ich würde sagen, so ein bisschen im Oberbauch
Also nicht unten im Bauch, wie wenn man zur Toilette muss oder so
Sondern eigentlich eher weiter oben, ja
Ja, links oder rechts?
Ja, auf der Seite, die ich hingefallen bin, ja
Nach der Unfall sind Sie auf die Toilette gegangen?
Zu Hause habe ich das versucht, aber ja, mein Freund hat mir da geholfen
Ich war kurz auf der Toilette, habe also einmal Wasser gelassen
Haben Sie vielleicht eine Bullet im Rindbärmett?
Ich habe mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, nein
Aber dann sind wir ja auch direkt hierher gekommen
Wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen im Bauch bereiten, beschreiben Sie uns hierher dummstichend?
Ich würde eher sagen, so drückendumpf, dumpfe Schmerzen so
Wie steht das in der Schmerz, auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10
1 steht für sehr leichte Schmerzen, steht für unerträgliche Schmerzen
Ja, also der Arm, das ist schon so, da würde ich schon sagen bei 8, das kann ich nicht gut aushalten
Und der Bauch vielleicht ein bisschen weniger, vielleicht so bei 6, 7 oder so
Und Kopfschmerzen habe ich auch, ja
Kopfschmerzen, können Sie bis Ende des Gesprächs dieses Schmerz aushalten
oder das wollte ich Ihnen ein Schmerz empfehlen?
Das wird ja jetzt nicht mehr ewig dauern, ja
Lassen Sie, machen Sie mal ruhig weiter
Ja, okay
Und Sie haben da gesagt, dass Sie Kopfschmerzen haben
Wo genau verspüren Sie diese Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe eigentlich wie so ein Dröhn im ganzen Oberkopf so
Vielleicht so ein bisschen ähnlich, als wenn man ein bisschen viel getrunken hat oder so
Sie haben Helm getragen dabei?
Ja
Haben Sie vielleicht beim Unfall mit dem Kopf hingefallen oder?
Ich glaube schon, dass ich mit dem Kopfschmerz gestoßen bin, ja, ich glaube schon
Aber der Helm hat da wahrscheinlich das meiste abgehalten, ja
Okay
Sind Sie jetzt, oder ist Ihnen jetzt übel oder haben Sie...
Ein bisschen übel ist mir, ja
Und schwindelig ist mir auch ein klein bisschen, ja
Ich würde mich jetzt nicht sicher auf den Beinen fühlen
Übel und Schmerz
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auch hüfte Schmerzen haben
Ja, also die ganze Seite, ich denke ich bin einfach auf die linke Seite gefallen
Und das ist jetzt längst nicht so schlimm wie der Arm, ja
Ich glaube, der Arm hat am meisten abbekommen
Können Sie auftreten in Ihrem Beinen?
Ja, doch, das ging, ich bin ja auch hierher gelaufen
Haben Sie vielleicht eine Schwellung in Ihrem Hüftbereich, Bämmer?
Ja, ich glaube das ist alles blau da an der Seite, ja
Also ich war auf der Toilette, habe ich das gesehen, dass das so ein bisschen unterlaufen war
Das war schon ein bisschen gerötet
Das wird wahrscheinlich jetzt ein paar Tage, wird das blau sein
Haben Sie auch in Ihren Dinken Beinen krippen oder tapas gefühlt, Bämmer?
Nein, nein, da krippelt nichts, nein
Auf Temperaturunterschied?
Nein, nein, nein, also da ist, das ist glaube ich nur ein bisschen, dass ich da blau Flecken habe
Okay, ich möchte noch etwas wissen über Ihre, alle meine Zustand wissen, Frau Thomas
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich in letzter Zeit übrig?
Nein, nein, also ich war, ich bisher war ich fit, ich meine ich habe ewig lange jetzt schon
eine Schildrüse Geschichte, aber da nehme ich ja regelmäßig meine Medikamente
und damit bin ich eigentlich jetzt gut klar
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser lassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, ich habe gerne mal Verstopfung, ja da muss ich dann ein bisschen nachhelfen mit der Ernährung
aber normalerweise, also kriege ich das ganz gut hin
und im Wasser lassen, vor Jahren hatte ich mal eine heftige Nierenbeckenentzündung, ja
und das war dann halt sehr schmerzhaft beim Wasser lassen, aber da habe ich jetzt die letzten Jahre zum Glück keine Stiligkeiten
Okay, Frau Pseindag, und wie sieht Ihre Appetit aus, haben Sie eine Appetit Veränderung in Ihrer letzten Zeit?
Appetit, nein, also ich habe schon eigentlich einen guten Appetit, ja
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder siege mal?
Nein, nein, können Sie gut schlafen?
Eigentlich so, ja
Okay, ich möchte einige Fragen von Ihrer Krankengeschichte stellen, Frau Thomas
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Schildbrüse und Probleme haben
Ja, ich habe Paschimotortour, die das, ne?
Und ich muss halt älter Rucksin nehmen, da nehme ich aber auch, glaube ich, nicht so eine hohe Dose,
es ist nur morgens eine Tablette
Morgens eine Tablette, wie viele Milanmüsse sind?
Das ist älter Rucksin 75
75, okay
Haben Sie noch andere Krönchen erkrankt, zum Beispiel Luka krankheit, Bluthoch, Turuk?
Nein, nein, nein, sonst habe ich es immer, alles okay
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nee, noch nie
Okay
Sind bei Ihnen irgedwärtsche Allergien oder Unfallzwechstkeit bekannt?
Ja, also eine heftige Allergie habe ich, das ist auch Binnengift, ja
Da habe ich auch so einen Adrenalin-Pen im Sommer bei mir
Wenn ich gestochen werde, gleich etwas machen kann, das ist so ein bisschen dramatisch,
aber sonst ist eigentlich nur noch eine harmlose Allergie gegen braunes Pflaster da
Braunes Pflaster
Ja, also wenn ich dieses klebende braune Pflaster habe, dann kriege ich halt sofort so rote Picklechen da auf der Stelle, wo der Kleber ist
Was bekommen Sie, habe ich nicht verstanden, rote?
Picklechen, so ein Ausladung
Okay
Aber haben Sie keine Unfallzwechstkeit?
Nee, also Sie meinen jetzt bei Lebensmitteln oder was?
Ja, ich meine
Nee, ich kann nicht alles essen, ja
Okay, gut
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus, Frau Thomas?
Ja, ich bin natürlich gegen Corona geimpft, klar
Vollständig, okay
Gut
Okay, ich möchte noch etwas wissen über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten wissen, Frau Thomas, rauchen Sie?
Nee, rauchen Sie mich nicht
Haben Sie noch nie geraucht?
Nee, ich bin nicht rauchhorin
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Regelmäßig würde ich das nicht nennen, hin und wieder mal, wenn es mal etwas zu feiern gibt, oder also wirklich selten eher
Was trinken Sie gern?
Ich trinke gerne Cocktails
Im Sommer trinke ich auch mal ein Bier
Und im Winter, ja zu einem guten Essen trinke ich auch gerne ein Manglas Wein
Aber ja, das kommt nicht so oft vor
Okay, lutenmäßig muss ich fragen, ob Sie einen Tag mit Drogen haben?
Mit Drogen?
Ja, ich war mal so geneigt, ich wollte mal Marihuana probieren, aber dann musste ich so husten
Weil ich ja das rauchen gar nicht gewöhnt bin und dann habe ich das auch wieder eingelassen hier
Okay
Sind Sie regelmäßig bei Ihren Frauenarzt?
Ja, natürlich, klar, ja, ja
War das alles okay?
Das ist immer alles in Ordnung, ja, ja
Ich möchte noch wissen über Ihre Familiengeschichte
Sind bei Ihrem Eltern chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Also, ich weiß, mein Vater, der ist ja natürlich auch noch nicht alt, aber der hat vor zwei Wochen so eine Bypass-Operation im Herzen gehabt
Der hatte so verengte Herzgefäße
Das ist aber alles gut gesagt, meine Mutter ist so viel ich weiß, komplett gesund
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich bin ja auch noch nicht so alt, bitte?
Okay, Gott sei Dank, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Tillingschwester, ja
Ist sie gesund?
Also körperlich ist sie gesund, aber die ist belastet, die hat eine ausgeprägte Depression
Das macht uns natürlich ein bisschen Sorgen, ja
Okay, was machen Sie beruhig?
Ich bin auch Studentin
Studentin?
Was studieren Sie?
Ich studiere Germanistik und Philosophie
Haben Sie Stress dabei?
Ja, so eigentlich nur Prüfungsstress, aber eigentlich ist, ja, so Stress ist etwas anderes, ja
Wohnen Sie allein?
Ich wohne mit Freunden zusammen in der Wohngemeinschaft
Okay, wisst Ihr Familienstadt?
Ich bin leh nicht, ich bin leh nicht
Haben Sie keine Kinder?
Nein, keine Kinder haben ich auch noch nicht
Okay
Ich bin keine Frage mehr, Frau Thomas, haben wir alles besprochen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, eigentlich, das ist schon, ja wichtig ist jetzt eigentlich, dass wir gucken, was mit dem Arm ist
und dass wir auch vielleicht, dass ich etwas gegen die Schmerzen bekomme, ne?
Ja, ich werde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen
dann nehmen wir noch Blutab und machen ein bisschen Röntgenbild in Ihrem Arm und Hüften
dann besprechen wir, was das Problem sein könnte
Okay, und sehen wir, wie es weitergeht
Ja, ja, das ist gut
Wie immer, die Frage, möchte von den Kollegen jemand etwas wissen?
Ja, hat jemand Fragen, bitte Kollegen stellen hier Fragen, wenn Sie haben
Herr Kollege, brauchen Sie Zeit für Passionsvorstellung oder können Sie jetzt fragen?
Kann direkt weitergehen oder wollen Sie, wollen Sie noch ein bisschen sich sortieren?
Ein bisschen sortieren
Bitte geben Sie uns, wenn Sie bereit sind
Okay
Schönen guten Abend Frau Berersen
gerade habe ich eine neue Patientin gesehen, die Ihnen vorstellen möchte, hättest Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Es handelt sich um Frau Claudia Thomas, er ist 28 Jahre alt, 1,74 m groß, 79 kg schwer
Sie wurde in Begleitung von ihrem Freund bei uns nach einem Fahrradunfall
vor einer halb Stunden vor
Sie sei auf dem Weg
und konnte den Bauchschild spät sehen
und musste Sie Notfall bremsen
Und es dann gestört?
Dann ist sie auf ihrer linken Seite gestört
Sie klagte über Schmerzen
in ihrem linken Schulter
und Bauchschmerzen
Sie gab an, dass Sie Kursebeutel sein Verlust zu haben
Sie gab an, Kursebeutel sein Verlust zu haben
Dabei hatte sie einmal Emesis
Sie gab aber nicht während Sie bewusstlos war, sondern als Sie wieder bei sich waren
Während Sie bewusstlos war, hat sie sich übergeben?
Ich klingel nach dem Unfall
Nach dem Wiederaufwachen
Sie erwähnte, dass Sie beim Unfall einen Helm getragen haben
Das ist richtig, ja
Sie haben eine Schmerz
Sie haben eine Bewegung mit Schmerz
Sie bewertete die Schmerzintensität mit 8 auf eine Schmerzkammer
Sie klagte keine weiter neurologischen Ausfälle wie Posterin
Sie klagte auch Abdominalschmerzen mit Schmerzintensität
Sie bewertete die Schmerzintensität im Bauchbereit
Sie beschreibt die Schmerz im Bauchbereit als drückende Dumpf
Sie hat auch Danzen Kopfschmerzen
Sie bewertete die Anamnese
Sie bewertete die Obstifation
Sie bewertete die Anfohrerkrankung
Sie bewertete die Schmerzintensität
Sie bewertete die Obstifation
Sie bewertete die Anfohrerkrankung